that's just a taste
in many cases though it is an inside job
you know there is somebody in a museum
who knows
about what's going to take place hi my
name is octave durham nicknamed oki
i did more than ten thousand burglaries
i robbed everything you can imagine from
museums banks armor trucks but i never
used any violence my name is arthur
brent i'm an art detective and i'm
responsible for recovering 250 million
of stolen art we now work together in
trying to prevent archives today we're
going to watch art heights clips from
hollywood movies and we're going to
judge how realistic they are
i know one museum who has lasers it's
the consistency museum in vienna but
i don't think it's like this you know
you can dance
around these laces that i'm like what is
this copperware stuff are you nuts this
is this does not exist
even if it would exist like this
not touching any one of these laces is
impossible it's impossible even if you
would have seen them if you would see
them you know without using any spray or
something it's impossible to lose
to practice to do this little dance it
will take you about a year
the whole collection is gone
what you see now is going in the air and
you'll be dancing still with your lasers
i never uh studied the alarm for a long
time i mean when you see a building you
see how i'm going to get in and i see
this system and it will be
yeah uh studied in a minute it's a
system that i can do can hack or not
there must have been a lot of sensors
right i think at least
20 or something is always one or two or
three
two in a corner they take the whole area
i really doubt if if technology will
ever be that perfect to prevent art
thefts from happening
because you know there is always a
button you can switch off
and even if they can't find a button you
know they come in with a gun
the average burglar would do would not
do this because he doesn't have the
skills or uh the
balls to do it because it looks very
scary the skater jail
if you can't do the time don't do the
crime i did crimes i could do the time i
did a lot of time
[Laughter]
i give this movie
a 10 no kidding a zero
freshness gallery clothes for cleaning
cleaning yeah
doing it right now
you never talk to a guard
otherwise you could remember your face
you always
avoid to see a guard
upstairs set us down to clear this
exhibit
these are the fake guards it's
impossible to be in a museum and to me
this guy is
too heavily guard he has like a taser
and
it's impossible in in the netherlands
he's not even allowed
[Music]
[Applause]
i've never seen this these because
probably they access some maybe in the
louvre when it happens when the alarm
goes off it goes down
and they use something like it could be
like that but in a museum
doesn't go down most of the time if they
have walls like that it goes down uh
when they when they are closed and they
connect them to the ground or to the
wall they don't open up anymore but it
doesn't come all of a sudden when a
alarm goes off because the painting
comes off the wall
oh my god
you know you can make this up well
apparently you can he takes an oil
painting and he folds it in two
can you imagine
the painting is is nailed on a wooden
stretcher so it breaks the frame most of
the time together is with some what's
called plexiglas you know
so you won't get it out because it's
connected to each other you really have
to take some time to disconnect it from
each other heist especially artists are
normally done by by a gentleman thief
but the reality is different normally
these heists are linked to organized
crime
i have to deal with mobsters with
miracles with terrorists to give you one
example the the second most searched
painting on second on the fbi most
wanted list is the caravaggio it was
stolen in 1969 in palermo
and it said that it's it's being
displayed at meeting between mafia
bosses
so that's the kind of people we have to
deal with
most of the time when it comes to
burglaries it's a human error because
you must imagine if you're in a museum
nothing ever happens so if something
happens everybody panics and they don't
know they forgot their rules they get
mixed up a rate all right a tree
every transaction meticulously recorded
for posterity in the family ledger you
see two paintings that i was stolen but
they were not
in the movie they were at my friend's
house you see the two paintings that
made octave famous the two van goghs
that he stole in 2002
but in reality they were not there on
this on their couch but it was under his
bed he sold it to a
mafia boss in italy who later used these
paintings
to get a lesser sentence so luckily they
came back
in one piece and yeah and a few some of
the times you have people who steal it
and they figure out that they can't sell
it and they panic right and they they
destroy it when this happened in the
city the blacklist my telephone crashed
i was after him and now that he has
stopped doing these things we are
working together trying to get
these things prevented from happening
you know arthur has his contacts he's
got some information he doesn't tell me
everything i go out on the streets talk
to my people they don't talk to him
and in the middle we figure things that
other people can solve this is your
chance to solve a century and a half's
worth of abductions and thefts
so for me it was something
that i could make some money i never
knew that people uh got hurt if
paintings are stolen
i didn't understand at the time i do
right now understand that people get
hurt
uh if pain isn't stolen and that's one
of the reasons i get some paintings back
now
10 out of 10. tell me about this one
also from benin 7th century
fula tribe i believe
nah
it was taken by british soldiers in
benin but it's from wakanda
she's like the director of the museum
and nobody approaches
the director doesn't approach or anyone
a guy art stolen from africa is a hot
item these days
countries from africa are demanding
these pieces back from western museums
because they were stolen during colonial
era
and many of these objects do have a
spiritual meaning for these countries
and in fact i was one of the first last
year who brought such one of such pieces
back an empress crown stolen from
ethiopia and we brought it back and we
hand it over to the prime minister in
ethiopia
i'm gonna take a break
it is an inside job you know there is
somebody in it in a bank or in a museum
who knows
about what's going to take place it's
very easy to get somebody inside very
easy
i did these things you know you have to
find somebody who has problems you know
as depth or something i trace them where
they go where they go out
and then i bump up them saying i'm sorry
you want something to drink but also a
strange thing they come with their open
face he wants to be noticed
he attracts attention yes too much
that's just a taste
the problem with museums is that they
are there for the public
they are not it's not meant to be
affording so it's very hard to really
prevent
everybody from from taking something you
cannot put every painting like the mona
lisa behind
such thick class
i've never heard of an art theft where
people were killed you know
they shoot people here like it's
you know it's war it's not like that
let's say you have stolen art uh from a
crime like this you cannot sell it it's
too hot people died you cannot sell it a
ridiculous clip
this is a mission impossible it's really
a mission impossible it is it's too
much of a risk to
absolute guy down with a guy just
holding a rope if it goes through his
hands he would drop that he has no
control
this is
i cannot even imagine doing this he's
half naked there's one case i know of
that they did this upsiding it was a
couple of years ago in england in a
warehouse
they upselled into this warehouse and
the robbie took five hours
and they stole
200 rare books amongst them first
editions of
galileo for example worth 3 million
he hangs on top of the
yeah what is it a case
and he's
yeah sweaty as hell but at that time
they didn't have dna so it was possible
at the time but now if you do that they
come and get you after i think two weeks
there will be a child in real it's very
heavy i think it's even impossible to
lift it up the way they do it you know
you need a certain sort of head
hydraulics you know how to do this
this replacing is interesting because it
does happen the most spectacular case
was in 20 years ago in venezuela
a guy was walking around visiting art
galleries and he wanted to sell them a
painting called odeliskin red pants made
by henry matisse
but everybody laughed them away and they
said look this is a fake because the
real one is in a museum in venezuela so
everybody laughed and
cut them out but there was one art
dealer who got suspicious so he called
the museum and he said is this painting
still in your museum and they looked at
the painting and then they found out
that the painting in the museum was a
forgery so somehow someone had changed
the real one
for a fake one can you imagine you think
you have two real painting two real van
goghs and you sell them to a
heavy guy and he finds out it's fake
you're dead
things like this have happened so let's
give it you know i give it a seven what
do you give it i'll give it a four
it's fun to
you watch go to your own house after you
just stole the painting and uh him
touching everything with his bare hands
he doesn't have a hand glove on you
never touch the painting with your
bearings because of the dna
fingerprints a couple of years ago they
found a stolen day car in in a suitcase
in a bus so the police asked all the
passengers but nobody claimed the
painting of course so it does happen
that they put it in suitcases
most paintings i've seen are always been
in a bag trash bag or something for a
trash can back right or a spot back
you got a warrant
i don't need a warrant i'm not a cop
but these guys are
a mistake that's often made in hollywood
movies
interpol does not have
agents in the field making arrests
interpol is an agency that collects
information and distributes it around
the world
it's very important work but these these
men and women are sitting behind the
desk but over and over again hollywood
takes them from their desk gives them a
gun and let them makes a rest so
this just doesn't happen i know it's
true because i got extradited interpol
he was talking to the spanish cops and
he never said a word to me and he went
away he just opened the doors at the
airport put me into a plane
i love all the little dots
it's very artistic
there are not many are detectives in the
world you know police officers who
dedicate themselves to art there are few
some of them do have knowledge of art
but some of them have no clue
but
let's be honest the way he handles this
painting is likely they wouldn't allow
him to touch the parent like that
i would say a five six
a tree
they're all back on
this is
unrealistic really and and i never heard
of of a cctv camera being override i
think it might have happened you know
especially secret services probably use
this kind of stuff
but i don't know of a museum robbery
that this took place if your security
system goes down like an error i'm sure
they have uh
regulations or protocol what they have
to do check everything you have cameras
obvious and hidden cameras of course but
what strikes me a lot is that in many
cases
when a theft happens i called the police
and said well is the camera for this
no because
they were repairing cameras it's like
all the cameras in our museums the whole
what the whole year they are
being repaired he can't write his name
or read a book
saves behind hidden behind
paintings that does happen but thieves
know that of course so that's the first
place they look and if they don't know
the moment they take a painting of the
wall to steal it they see the safe and
they think oh my god we have a bonus
that happened with me a couple of times
i never was looking for a safe
i took a painting hey you gotta say
you see so don't try this at home don't
do it
the door is the most difficult thing
because it's very thick and the
mechanism and stuff like that you always
go
through the wall underneath the safe the
back of the safe the weak spot you know
life is what you wish i listened to
music when i was on my way
to get uh you know get some adrenaline i
would say like four yeah three or four i
don't think you've been properly
introduced
sam it's your neighbor mr rembrandt
the guy who's standing next to clooney
is based on a real character his name is
harry etlinger as a little kid a jewish
kid in germany he was living in
karlsruhe a few blocks away from the
museum where this painting was hanging
and as a child he wanted to see this
painting but he was not allowed he was
jewish they didn't allow him
into this museum
a couple of years later his family
fled for the nazis to the united states
and when the war started
harry
joined the army and this unit
they had to track down all the arts
stolen by art of hitler they went into a
salt mine in not aussie in austria and
harry to his surprise saw this same
painting this rembrandt so he couldn't
believe it
as an american sergeant he brought it
back himself what a story
the nazis stole
millions of pieces of art there was
given an order to blow everything up
but the second man in command from the
ss carlton bruno prevented it
so in the end
this wasn't blown up they found all
these pieces back
this is an interesting scene here you
see a painting called portrait of a
young man by rafael and this one is
considered to be the most important
painting still missing from world war ii
this one
but
it probably wasn't in this
salt mine to begin with even i am still
searching for this particular painting
the nazis did destroy art but that was
modern art you know the order was given
to destroy them but it didn't take place
for reality i would give it like a nine
this painting there
the duke of wellington by francisco was
really stolen in 61. and in 62 when this
movie was shot
it still was lost
the makers started to be a little in
joke to put it in the movie the real
thief was caught a few years later after
this movie it was not dr no it was a
taxi driver from london it influenced a
lot of of thieves so they steal a
painting and then they are going to
search for a doctor no to sell it to
but there are not many doctor notes
because why would you buy a stolen
painting if you have the money to buy a
real one you cannot show a stolen
painting to your friends to your
children
so
there are not that many doctor knows
but
the police knows so they decide to play
along
so if you meet a doctor no most likely
it's an
undercover cup you know it's james bond
so let's give it a 10.
i i don't watch that many hollywood
movies you know because with the kind of
work i do sometimes i have the feeling
i'm in one of myself i once recovered a
stolen picasso worth 70 million but
before handing it back to the owner i
put it on my wall for one night so i
imagine it's totally because of worth 70
million on my wall there is only one guy
in the world who knows what it is to
have these kind of stolen paintings on
this wall
so i called aki and i said you have no
idea what's on my wall and he said well
tell me he said i stole him because i'm
worth 17 million
so he went quiet for a few seconds and
then he said is there any chance you're
leaving your home
thank you for watching if you want to
see more click the video above